what do liberal congressman and wieners
have in common
stay tuned to find out no really I'll
tell you so it's one year since the
health care bill has been passed it's
done we have it now
but there are some people who have a
problem with its inefficiency and
overbearing costs however no not those
people
I'm speaking of course of people just
like Anthony Weiner the New York City
congressman who recently asked for a
waiver from Obamacare but wait wasn't he
one of the biggest supporters of the
health care bill you asked to you I say
stop asking questions
besides I did it for you that's right
earlier today I actually sat down with
mr. Weiner to ask him on his thoughts
congressman thank you for taking the
time you're looking well signs you know
idx let's get right to it you were one
of the health care bills biggest
supporters what's ROI yet now you're
asking for a waiver uh-huh how do you
justify that well the good people of New
York can't afford the burden of
Obamacare right now but you knew that
when you sign the bill right but I only
did that knowing that I could get a
waiver
now isn't that hypocritical I don't
understand the question and I won't
respond to it
is it hot in here I feel like I'm
plumping so a year after it's been
passed over a thousand waivers to
Obamacare have been given out with over
45% of them going directly to this
administration's labor union allies and
so I asked if the supporters of this
bill can get waivers what about its
opponents and that's why I'm here to
tell you about a site today called
where's my waiver calm that's where's my
waiver dot-com where you can go today
and demand your waiver to Obamacare
unless you're a we these are good people
oh I can't stay mad at you Weiner oh I
wish I held an office like that Weiner
that is where I'll truly like to be for
if I held an office like that mean
then the law would not apply to me give
me your money
you